one thing that we wanted to make
available on the platform is continuity
potentially to other methods and people
that people are using in the lab or
other courses that you're thinking
coding and visualization what we did and
you can see in this little video is
after you complete a pipeline you
probably notice that there's an
occipital called our pack so for example
PCA will have a whole zip file called
PCA are high now we're gonna take some
of these are files and show you how to
modify them but there's where everything
is a little bit more clear you can
generate those yourself okay now let's
go to the folder called five platform
our Suites here we prepared for suites
for dealing with PCH clustering or SVM a
stepwise Lda today let let us consider
PCA and here we have PCA dot our file
do you have an art studio yeah great we
can open it
okay and he will see the car each file
starts with needed libraries so you can
install them in order to run this do you
know how to install the various
libraries are just install packages I
think you have ggplot2 if you have our
school year and we can just simply run
it and that's all we have t see a plot
dot PDF on it already and we see just
one flick and sweet works okay let's go
through it we see options from the
platform remember we were selecting
something like transpose Center scale
how many principal components to grow in
the web interface and here we have all
these options in the code so you just
can modify input file we can transpose
the data or not centered data scale and
so on so this is just simple script not
not so simple as if you write it by your
own hands but okay so let's start just
look by code chunks first we read the
data so we have it has header we have
row names in first column and that so
then it's option to transpose the data
so we have done it we have already done
it for you so you know transposing the
data rate are sometimes not so simple
because we have some text columns text
rows and this all are already handled
yep then we assign some group names and
here's a main line calling PC ages PRC
from function is from stats package
already insult in the are building
package and then about drawing he will
see PDF and if you are writing and by
the script or something else perhaps you
want more beautiful plot than this is
yep so you can modify this string and we
have already improved script in our code
directory we have a phone holder - it is
a file for generating such pictures so
you see that we have where percent of
variation explained by the principal
components you will see some group
labels and we have sample names instead
of points and let's see how we can
modify our script to draw beautiful
beautiful pictures so you see that first
first robes are probably at the same we
just 12 the data that with the tables
transpose it here we expose assign
numeric numeric class expressions
okay let's see how we can visualize in
previous in platform code we use ggplot2
library and he we used GG 45 libraries
just and package able to pca plots and
here we see
how it works the function is called out
of blood he will play he would pass
result of PCA so here I applied PCA and
I passed this object to the justice
argument then I say from which column to
take colors to our roots here I have
some data frame called groups with
column with group names and I say that
please take the colors from that data
frame then I have option label is true
which just rows label names of this plot
and yes I can label size shape equal
false let me set it to true and see what
happens and now I removed shape equal
false and I see points you some shape so
see if it's just a argument for drawing
points I think that they are not needed
now it's more beautiful without them
okay and then frame is just for growing
these Alexes
and here we have option frame type and
just for practice please remove it and
look what happens
that's runs go by yourself
and you see that we have polygons
instead of okay so and I have commented
there are some other options which are
perhaps hard to understand because there
are some mathematical meaning but let's
let us uncomment these streams and see
what will happen okay so these arrows
are called loadings and what it what
does it mean let us imagine for example
three dimensional space and three axis
you know they are orthogonal to each
other and what actually can see a to eat
select one more set of axis for example
just like this and then may make a
projection to to through them and then
we can project initial access to so
these axes are projections of initial
axis and our initial axis was gene names
yeah so for each arrow we have gene name
and how do you interpret this picture
for example let's take this thing we can
see if we grow by direction of this
arrow then expression of these genes is
growing so and we see that these two
groups are located these two groups and
this group are located just on the line
of this arrow so if follows then big
values of restrain expression are
associated with these two groups and
small values with these
so we can just go by these arrows and
see how the gene expression effects to
the separation of the groups so it is
really important and we see that some
genes are not important you know that
we've expression bearers of these queens
mainly correspond to the disprove
because arrow goes here and small values
correspond to these two groups so it's a
yeah so better projection of initial
axis which really makes sense to use
yeah and most long arrow is the most
informative gene in our case okay okay
and that's about at PCA
remember we created a heat map and we've
seen that to obtain much information we
need to replace columns just by colors
and this is really difficult to do
manually and we can use heat map in our
and it automatically does this column
replacement and we will see a really
beautiful heat map which indicates that
this is the first group second we have a
code for it in our code direction
there's a heat map folder and we can't
open it okay
started just pretty same that in PCA we
just long the data and transposed
because all all machine learning methods
actually wants to sample the row name's
not colonies but for biology is more
convenient to use it back home so we
need to expose them each time here I
have huge eat nap call and less reduce
it and step by step up and some options
and see what they actually mean now that
is you see power of are just comparing
with Excel but here we have some your
article clustering which orders these
wrong these groves and here you see just
some groups that they are all red with
green and just they are all sorted in
proper way so let us see how it works
and which options do we have
let's go eat taste here and command this
one and remove all options from here so
calling these map from scratch art
okay
that's how it looks you can just remove
all options from these poll just leave
expressions so first we have some
density plot on the color key that means
that red values are used more frequently
than these yellow values yep so we have
what a lot of red cells varied map but
actually people don't like this and we
want to remove it so for that we can use
density information no here we run and
see no density information now about
these strange lines near strange traces
what is that at each column we have some
dashed line which indicates the mean
expression level here is it just orange
color and if our value is lower than
mean level then solid line is drawn at
left of this dashed dashed line and if
it is yellow its it has drawn at the
right so I don't know why it should be
used and why it is the default option in
heat map to function so every time you
want to draw heat map first of all you
put these options here just to prevent
traces and density Oh
then okay and then or he'd met with more
who you are now what we want that then
we see that our gene names are not
fitting in our PDF they are truncated
here so we can add some margins for
example 12:12 you can modify these
values as you want and you see that now
really treated you okay and then we see
that row name sample names are covering
each other
and we want to reduce font size or that
we have option C X row so zero point
five point five is a percent related to
the initial font scale so when I type
zero point five it means please add font
size two times two times less than
initial one when when we run it we see
that they are not overlapping here and
this is great and the most challenging
part is them to mark groups in this pot
because we know that H clustering it's
just hierarchical cluster here it will
ordered our rows and we see some groups
you for example we see yellow they're
red they're wrong right there and we
think that this reordering actually
matches with our groups or for clinical
times and we want to add some colors to
indicate which group is where for each
there's a there's an option called rows
colors in which you need to pass array
of colors associated with each of the
group needs so for that we should
prepare this array first so we have a
array called groups let us print it and
see what it what it is here is goop goop
is just an array top line is a header
will group names and we want to convert
them into the colors for that we
initialize an empty array of repellers
iterate through groups and just some ifs
if normal like orange and so on and
after that we append a deist color to
their o colors array just by calling C
do you know what C means in our C's just
for creating an RA arrays so we just
concatenate to embrace various line and
then we can pass this option to the heat
map and see that thing that which is not
possible to do in Excel you see that
thisis luminal group and I don't
remember you same sense their colors but
[Music]
so yes and one more thing there that
remember we set linkage type to work dot
let's let us see now let me run this and
we see that there are some some kind of
not perfect reordering
you see that this group is splitted by
orange group and there are two luminal
types so word dot d tu is just another
modification of all the eldery which
affects to the way how distances between
clusters are calculated and if we append
this long long line here it will use
this linkage type for for tender grams
and here you will see better clustering
and here we see for example an outlier
here is it and it's actually luminal but
it's more similar to wait
you